Da.
Deci, mergând mai departe, bits-urile
și qubit-urile vor fi paradisul computațional fundamental
cu care putem aborda
probleme complexe din lume
deci haideți să înțelegem diferența dintre ele
și de unde vine puterea qubit-urilor
dacă ne uităm pe partea stângă
e o modalitate de a descrie și vom folosi aceste diagrame
pe parcursul prezentării pentru a
ilustra puterea — vedem un cerc
și două puncte; când punctul e la polul nord
înseamnă zero, când e la polul sud înseamnă unu
ăsta e un bit clasic cu două stări; un qubit este
unitatea de informație în lumea cuantică
și aici avem o imagine mai completă
e ca o sferă — zero sau unu
și le putem avea în această stare de superpoziție
avem un truc special la dispoziție
nu doar că le putem poziționa pe această sferă
dar imaginați-vă că fiecare dintre acestea
e ca o lună mică
care se află pe această sferă și putem roti luna
deci aici vedeți că
sfera de jos a fost rotită puțin
de aceea vedeți un pic de albastru
și roz, și am putea s-o rotim complet
deci aici avem o rotație de o sută optzeci de grade
deci avem această noțiune de fază pe care cuantica ne-o oferă
trei superputeri care se manifestă în qubit-uri
acestea sunt puterile superpoziției
puterea interferenței
și puterea entanglementului
deci haideți să le explorăm — principiul superpoziției este de fapt
destul de simplu de înțeles
deci la stânga
avem fie polul nord zero, fie polul sud unu
și dacă adăugăm acele două stări
acum avem un qubit în superpoziție care are atât
zero cât și unu simultan — nord
și sud; diagrama din dreapta e la fel
dar acum vom face un mic truc
vom aplica un gate, un quantum gate
pe ce am făcut — amintiți-vă
putem schimba, putem
roti aceste luni mici, nu-i așa?
deci am rotit-o o sută
și optzeci de grade și acum avem un unu
deci acum când facem adunarea zero plus unu ajungem
la o stare de superpoziție
dar observați că e diferit
față de cel din stânga — avem
tot zero și unu, dar acum cu starea rotită
pentru unu; acum asta va fi foarte puternic
pentru a exploata un al doilea lucru cu adevărat interesant, care este
principiul interferenței
și aceasta nu este o operație pe care o putem efectua în lumea clasică
a biților; deci aici în acest exemplu avem
un zero și unu la stânga, plus
această nouă stare pe care am creat-o
care e tot zero și unu
dar cu această lună rotită; când facem asta acum
putem face să interfereze cele două stări
și observați că s-a întâmplat ceva cu adevărat interesant
am anulat starea unu
și am ajuns cu starea zero
am reușit asta pentru că am făcut să interfereze stările
deci oportunitatea următoare pe care o avem acum
este câte stări putem crea
și lucrul frumos în cuantică este că putem crea un număr exponențial
de stări; deci haideți să privim un sistem care are
cinci qubit-uri; în acest caz reprezentăm aceste qubit-uri
ca qubit-uri independente — le vedeți în stânga
zerouri și unuri, și se înmulțesc — avem cinci
dintre ele, deci numărul de stări pe care le putem crea — sau
calculatorul cuantic reprezentat pe sferă în dreapta
este doi la puterea
numărului de qubit-uri pe care le avem; în acest caz avem cinci
deci doi la puterea cinci înseamnă treizeci și două de stări
deci vedem treizeci și două dintre acele luni mici
observați că în acest caz nu am încorporat
nicio fază — toate sunt roz; aspectul puternic al
utilizării acestei proprietăți numite entanglement în lumea cuantică
este că putem crea acum stări
ca cea reprezentată în dreapta
unde avem aceste combinații de roz
și albastru, unde acea stare nu poate fi descrisă
ca produsul independent al
acestor cinci qubit-uri; în acest caz
deoarece avem treizeci și două de stări
ceea ce ne spune asta este ceva cu adevărat profund